disco elysium the final cut is set for
release on march 30th
and it significantly expands the game
zoom released in october 2019
along with releasing on playstation 4
ps5 and stadia
with plans for switch and xbox versions
in the future the final cut adds new
quests
new characters and myriad small changes
throughout the game
that will allow players to solve
problems in new ways here's all the big
changes coming to the final cut
for more coverage like this video and
subscribe to our channel
the biggest difference between the
original disco elysium and the final cut
is a huge amount of new voice acting the
man
lands with a dull thump like a broken
down puppet of muscles
and sinew for a moment he still tries to
keep his head up
based eyes looking at you with
unimaginable surprise
the new version is fully voiced which
was a huge undertaking
according to voice over director jim
ascholivi disco elysium contains about a
million words that had to be voiced
which is about as many words as in all
the harry potter novels combined
whining about your back every time you
bring out the measuring tape
honey you're a man with a fork in the
world of soup
please let's just try to enjoy the game
all right it features performances by 59
actors from around the world
in order to capture the feeling that
disco setting
rabbishole is a melting pot of different
cultures and accents
the amount of new voice acting is what
you'll notice most in the final cut but
it's far from the only change
the new version includes four additional
quests that can be unlocked based on
your political
alignment depending on your choices in
interacting with other characters
and what you choose from disco elysium's
thought cabinet
you can wind up on one of four political
vision quests that add new characters
story and development to your
protagonist the four quests aren't all
the same length
but each will have a potential impact on
the later portion of disco elysium's
story
lead artist kaspar thomsolu says the
quest should offer players culmination
and catharsis
giving them a chance to explore their
characters different possible political
leanings
and learn more about the game's world
there are a lot of other
smaller improvements in disco elysium
the final cut as well
the game's frame rate has been improved
new art and music has been
added and there are new ways to solve
problems scattered throughout the game
so if you've played disco elysium before
you might want to check it out again
there are also new additions to make
streaming the game easier and more
interesting
the final cut includes a streaming mode
that will replace copyrighted music
throughout the game
and there are new twitch integrations
that will let players vote on streamers
actions as they play
thomsolu said you'll even be able to
vote to either increase or decrease a
streamer's stats while you watch
which could change how key moments in
the game play out
with the addition of political vision
quests and full voice acting
the developers say the final cut is
disco-elysium as they always
intended it to be and it should be a lot
easier to play on your couch when you
don't have to read a million words to
enjoy it
as you slam your fist on the button the
man collapses
entirely his head rolling to the side
looks like you're the new measure head
now
her voice is surprisingly calm no one is
the new measure head
let's go before he gets up if you want
to know more about disco elysium
we have an in-depth interview with
robert kirbitz its writer and lead
designer
about the feature that almost sank the
entire project
thanks for watching
[Music]
you